welcome to this video playing a young
broken man is this really young broken
man I don't know a young Brooklyn man
but it always interesting that I have
those their real names are real sounding
names in there is this really the person
is this really the name I came so we
have a comic-con and with d3 I just
played totally normal moose developing
yeah maybe I should make it a bit more
difficult for him to play be four very
solid way to play on as black I wonder
should I play a form a BF oh come on
that's disturb him a bit he goes before
I have fun I do I have a three young
maybe not not sure that it is Oh Rita is
taking didn't expect that really so
night night somewhere to get it back to
c5 and then he has may not really am but
I can also go here and take a form
conveniently
yeah PA for was a bit of estrangement
sometimes those slide provocations i do
do pay off it could have really just
them played before I think or ignore it
altogether okay so i have from some
slight pressure against c3 maybe it's
it's a good idea to to clarify here in
the center so that he cannot take on d5
at any point right here the structure is
already quite favorable here on the
queenside so it's no problem to fix the
center and make sure that for instance
is g2 bishop is not doing anything great
yeah h6 was to learn to control g5 so
that we should be six can be played more
conveniently yeah and maybe this wasn't
the most precise way to players he gets
in night see for him that's a that's not
great i mean i didn't see it that that's
the most that's the the the worst part
of it i can maybe take here i am
attacking c3
it looks a bit loose oh yeah i forgot
really that you can take on on d6 with
the Queen but ok there's no way back
here anyway and maybe that's not so bad
really i get i have what two points two
pawns and add the rook against two minor
pieces I can take a two yeah probably I
don't want to take d6 so that you can
you recapture with tempo it's not really
great so I've got three pawns now yeah
this is sounds nice but he will get some
stuff back pretty sure I mean you can at
least take on da de and take something
only five but very important that I got
the a porn so there is no danger of him
getting be seven and then suddenly the a
porn is a super dangerous super
dangerous force um I wonder I wonder how
to to get moving here the pawns I mean
I'm to kick it away here Bishop f5 as
maybe a good way ok now night is 7s on
should probably then you can take on b7
with check or maybe Bishop is 6 cm
where's the night going yeah that's
probably right taking the night maybe if
the night goes to III I have look d 2 d
2 just playing for the attack IAM on f 2
i'm not sure that you can take be some
really okay let's do it mmhmm yeah maybe
just back to see aid and now come on
let's do it back to the eighth covering
b7 for the moment I'm still attacking f2
uh-huh yeah but if I go rook f2 and then
look II to rock F 297 king of eight
nights e8 rookie to mmm Joe I'm not sure
really not sure at all okay 97 king of
eight nights e8 rookie to one hand I
detect is he has rock be three of course
he just has looked be three yeah this
was was stupid really stupid but anyway
what can I do so now he has got three
pieces for a rock and if I have a ton of
I have some ponds reports but basically
this was totally completely useless what
I did okay maybe I still can get to the
pawns rolling not easy time morning
very difficult the pieces are quite
quite decently coordinated yeah I mean I
must I must get them moving I'd be
sadness just hanging wow what a great
game yeah it's getting better and better
it's getting better and better check
check less than then see to look b3
seems I'm getting getting one night at
least ok so the worst is definitely over
20 24 seconds
yeah cannot really am expect great moves
here with this time night eh formerly it
looks weird to me putting it Callie edge
of the board check
also look takes h4 is just the drawn
because of yeah I don't know it's it's
it's rook takes h4 it's just a drone
check garage I can try to offer it to
him because its data but I know people
will just plan on time regardless of the
position yeah it's the wrong colored
colored bishop
what is it doing white forfeits on time
yeah I think this is just the just
results really if you just don't take
the drop and forget to take my pawn I'm
taking the point I have a offer to draw
yet what can I do it it is of course a
dead wrong the whole game was of course
totally bonkers what was I doing here
yeah maybe yeah this should be you
should be really okay but the whole idea
to here with rook t2 which was firmly
probably really really insane I mean two
points should be really good for me they
are connected king of seven maybe I mean
I don't know this is okay so the point
is and this this is just totally crazy I
can just play king of seven why not just
king of seven yeah yeah the thing is I
had forgotten well I had had not seen
that he can play can play rugby three I
tend to use forgotten in the wrong way I
mean I really mean I overlooked it I
didn't see it ruby three out and here
I'm just I'm just I'm just bad i don't
know i mean okay wit was um at the end
check i managed to somehow promote a
poem so that it actually gives a draw I
really think it's a row I just need to
hear I just need to take edge for as I
as I did
check okay and this is this is dead but
he's somehow I don't know you should
really take the pawn and I'll just agree
to the draw offer draw or whatever but
what can you do four points in the
pocket thanks for watching